A knitter is asking about knitting
swatches using DesignaKnit.
She has a Silver Reed electronic machine,
and with these machines,
in order to knit in pattern for her
swatches, she needs to use DesignaKnit.
She asked how she should set
the gauge to knit her swatch.
The answer is, it doesn't matter.
Let's explore why.
If you're using Stitch Designer and you're
creating a new stitch pattern,
it's important to set your gauge
similar to what you'll be knitting.
For example, these hearts knit at this
gauge are a little bit distorted
from knitting them at this gauge.
In Stitch Designer,
DesignaKnit uses your entered gauge
to display your stitch pattern.
It's up to you to design the hearts
so they look good at your gauge.
In designing stitch patterns,
there are no calculations like
in designing garment pieces.
So DesignaKnit it uses the gauge
to preview how a stitch pattern will look.
To knit a swatch, we'll
use Interactive knitting.
For this example, we'll use this
pretty hearts stitch pattern.
Open Interactive Knitting and tell DesignaKnit that you want to use
just the stitch pattern.
Now, we're not going to be
using the shape file.
For a standard gauge swatch,
it's common to cast on 60 stitches
and knit for 80 rows
so that you can measure 40 stitches gauges
in 60 rows and use a green
gauge ruler to measure.
Of course, you could choose to knit
your swatch any size you like.
DesignaKnit is going to display
a preview of the hearts as they will
look at the gauge that is currently set.
Now, if you change the gauge, you
can see the changes in this preview.
However, changing the gauge is not
impacting the number of stitches
and rows you're knitting.
No matter what gauge you set,
the display will change, but the stitches
and rows will remain the same.
You will establish your gauge by knitting
60 stitches and 80 rows,
and it may look very different than
the display in Interactive Knitting.